Vegeta what does the scouter say about
his power level it's over a hundred
thousand Oh what a hundred thousand
that's impossible no it's not impossible
not with awesome people like you I
[Music]
reached a hundred thousand subscribers
today and I decided to make a video
basically thanking you guys because you
are the best people ever my fiance
surprised me with something today I woke
up and in the kitchen was this I did not
expect that at all she knows I love
Nintendo Donkey Kong is perfect I just
can't believe she actually did that that
was so cool and I want to share with you
guys she also bought me these balloons
that are behind me these Batman
decorations and that Star Wars
decoration I came in my office was
totally nerded out and she had got me
this cake and it was a great celebration
and I just want to thank you guys so
much and since this is also my 600th
video and just so happens to be the
video in which I'm thanking you guys for
allowing me to reach a hundred thousand
subscribers I decided that I would do
something a little bit special I asked
on Twitter what you guys would like me
to do I said hey when I had a hundred
thousand subscribers I'll make a special
video what do you want me to do and you
guys said a lot of great suggestions but
one of the biggest things were just
talked a little bit about how you
started your life your love of movies
what made you want to start doing
reviews on YouTube and how that all
began and maybe give us something a
little bit special so I decided you know
what I will do that I'll give you guys
some clips of things some very old
reviews that are no longer on the
internet I will show you guys them and
all of their awful glory maybe a few
short film clips and maybe some clips of
me dancing yeah that actually exists
I've always loved movies as you guys
know and the majority of you guys
probably know that back in when I was a
teenager I saw some films and theaters
and I just got really inspired to want
to make films on my own and I got a
video camera that's really crappy like
mini DV tape camera and my friends and I
made hundreds of short movies throughout
our teenage years we made so many and I
have all of them saved to this day and
often times I will watch them and just
cry laughing cuz not only are they so
terrible on a technical level but
they're just so funny to watch even if I
showed you guys some of them you
wouldn't even get it because a lot of
the times back then my audience were my
friends so when I made a
comedy or I made something funny I tried
to entertain them because they were my
primary audience now you guys are my
audience and so I try to entertain you
guys and half the stuff I made back then
we're really just experiments like my
friends and I were like okay let's take
a big knife and we'll go outside and
we'll make like a killer that escaped
from some Asylum and he's out there you
know just really really really cliche
and stuff like that we did that kind of
stuff all the time and I have to tell
you those are some of the best years of
my life honestly it was blind
inspiration that's what I call it if I
had an idea we just filmed it we didn't
think about it we didn't take time to
plan it out we literally said Oh that'd
be cool and then we would start filming
it we'd make up lines on the spot we'd
make up endings on the spot it wasn't
anything that we really sat down and
worked hard to try to do like I do
nowadays when I write a short film back
then it was literally blind inspiration
I had an idea or someone else had an
idea and we just made it and it was so
much fun eventually I decided that I had
all of this information in me and it had
to get out somehow I wanted to tell
people about it I wanted to say this is
what I think of this movie and that way
he did the shot in that way she did her
performance and I just had to tell
people actually I vividly remember the
first time I thought about doing a
YouTube channel I was hanging out with
my dad actually I think we were playing
cards because my dad and I used to play
cards all the time we'd play various
card games and I was just sitting there
like it would be kind of cool if I
started something that was called quick
movie reviews and I would do very short
reviews like one minute long and that
way I didn't have to worry so much about
the editing process and I will just get
my thoughts on movies
my first review ever on that channel was
for movie Ponyo by Hayao Miyazaki and my
review was one minute and 13 seconds
long I basically was like yeah it was
pretty fun and enjoyable I actually
don't have that review saved anymore I
don't know where it is I lost it somehow
that channel was eventually deleted
because I wasn't sure if I wanted to
continue with it basically I wasn't
entirely sure where I was gonna go in my
life and what that was gonna be I had
some fun with those reviews and despite
the fact that this review is technically
very poorly done in my opinion I would
like to show you about 30 seconds of one
of my older reviews because that's about
all I can take these are not on the
internet anywhere here's an old old
review that I made and you can see that
I didn't really know what I was doing
George Clooney stars as Ryan Bingham a
man who is hired by companies to fire
people because they're afraid to do it
themselves he flies everywhere across
the United States all year are thinking
in the movie says that previous year he
was actually home for 42 miserable days
he loves being on the air he loves going
to all these different places because
the airplane his home that's where he
feels most comfortable and he meets a
woman played by Vera Farmiga I'm trying
to say her name all I can say is whoever
stuck with me since then you are to be
commended and I thank you because I
don't know how anyone watch me back then
I had no charisma I had nothing it was
just here's this movie and I still get
comments from time to time people who
are like I miss you back when you were
doing your quick movie reviews and I'm
like have you watched any of those
lately they're not good I'm not gonna
name this friend because she probably
wouldn't want me to do this but I
actually have a very good friend one of
my best friends who inspired me to start
reviewing again she sat me down and she
was like look do you miss reviewing
movies on YouTube and I was like yes I
do and she was like then why aren't you
doing it and I was like I don't know
and she was like why you enjoy talking
about movies you love giving your
opinion on movies you should do it and I
was just like you were right you are
right lady and I decided that I wanted
to start again and that is when I
launched this channel Chris Tucker and I
decided to call it my own name instead
of quick movie reviews because I felt
that the name quick movie reviews
restricted me to doing only that and if
I had my name I could do anything you
know it's just it's me it's my name so I
can do a review I can do a video game I
can do anything you know now there are
two reviews that really kind of
catapulted me beyond what I was at
because I reviewed a movie called
Dragonball Evolution it's my least
favorite movie of all time and I hate it
very much so and I also did a review for
The Last Airbender and it's funny
because the two reviews that actually
got me some notice on the internet are
horrible rants what actually happened
and what gave me my first legitimate
boost was a dragon ball protest page
that was protesting Dragonball Evolution
posted my review on their home page and
they had it on their home page for
something like a month or two it was
crazy and because of that I got like a
couple thousand subscribers overnight
and it was nuts it was crazy I woke up
and my video had thousands of views and
I had all these subscribers and it was
like wow and so I actually don't
remember the title of that page but
Thank You Dragon Ball protest page
because you are that first thing that
gave me that push out the door and this
story is really cool actually the chance
to see The Last Airbender before it came
out the review that you see for that
right now in my channel is not my
original upload that had been uploaded
previously irie uploaded it for this
channel due to requests but what
happened with that review is I had a
chance to see The Last Airbender like a
week early there were no critics reviews
for it out everyone was still really
excited for it like people legitimately
thought okay this is Shyamalan he's
gonna return this is gonna be incredible
it looks so awesome and I was actually
one of the first people to come out on
the internet and say that it was an
absolute garbage disaster of that
video had like 600 700 dislikes it was
like you suck you idiot it's good
amazing and I was like guys just just go
watch the movie okay now I can tell you
that around Friday or Saturday of that
weekend when the movie came out the
dislikes virtually stopped and the likes
just might like see I told you guys and
it was sort of like suddenly I had built
this credibility or something because
people were like that one guy who said
it sucked yeah he was the first person
who told me that and it was true and
that review got a lot of hits and I got
a lot of subscribers off that a few
thousand more subscribers and it wasn't
for like another year and a half even
that I was able to get partnered because
when I started on YouTube you couldn't
automatically get partnered you actually
had to work for it and then submit an
application to YouTube isn't that nuts
yeah you couldn't get ads or monetize
any of your videos when you started out
you had to legitimately work for it and
say look I'm gonna do this and support
me YouTube and they did about a year and
a half after I started and I have loved
doing these movie reviews ever since the
beginning honestly it's a way for me to
be able to just simply express my
opinion and I've learned so much about
the technical aspects of video making as
well that's something that really
surprised me because when I first
started I wasn't using a microphone and
I'm gonna hold this up but now I am this
is a professional microphone I'm using a
very high grade camera I have lights set
up and when I film my original videos I
was just sitting on a bed in my room
with one overhead light absolutely no
microphone and not the greatest quality
camera and I was just using what I had
at the time I've met so many cool people
along the way like my buddy John the
flick pick you know I've met him many
times we've hung out he's a great guy he
does awesome videos if you want to check
him out the schmoes in LA Jeremy John's
I met in LA so many great people I met
the entire pretty much it gang Paul Mike
Eric Jake Jake's one of my favorite
people I've had on YouTube honestly i
guy's hilarious he's really funny
what am I gonna say I was gonna say
check out jigs videos he does really
great game reviews on because video
games that's his channel but the very
first person I haven't mentioned this
yet for a reason a lot of people are
like hey what is the person you know
what's the thing that went I want to do
YouTube videos and yes I had the idea
just like I said I was with my dad and I
said I want to do movie reviews but then
I thought about it for a while and I
molded over and I wasn't sure yet until
I saw this one guy his name is Blake
Kennedy he doesn't do movie reviews
anymore he has recently started doing
more videos on the Internet his original
channel name was grounded for life 27
and I saw his movie reviews and he was
just this kid like in high school
talking about movies and he was
hilarious and he had like 800
subscribers at the time and I remember
going wow 800 people want to watch him I
need to try this out and I did and I
have him to thank and I still talked to
him every day we text each other we
talked on the phone I talked to him
every I talk to him like two days ago or
something he's an awesome guy I also
want to thank two people that are
extremely important to me and that is my
parents my parents have been endlessly
supportive of me in regards to this and
ever since I was 13 years old my mom is
the one who bought me the video camera
she said look you want to do this here
have fun and I was like this is the
greatest moment of my life
they've always been supportive of me and
they've always tried to do their best to
make me enjoy life and have fun things
to do and I just want to thank them for
that too I also want to thank my fiancee
she's given me a lot of inspiration as
well and she's given me a lot of really
great ideas that scary movie night we
did last October that was mostly her
idea now I want to thank my earliest fan
who's been watching me since I was doing
short movies on YouTube I had a channel
where I was uploading short films that
channel is no longer there but he stuck
with me from that all the way to my
critics reviews
I mean it's nuts I'm not gonna say his
full name just in case he wouldn't want
me to cuz I didn't tell him I was gonna
do this but his name is Gus thank you
sir
you have been with me forever you still
talk to me it's awesome I can't even
explain you're probably my first real
fan and that's really great but people
like him have been with me since my
Indiana Jones films which I know guys
you want me to I can't upload them they
have so much John Williams music they'll
get copyright notices I
do it but I'll try to find a way to
upload them on another site in the
future maybe like vo
or something like that you guys have
seen me doing my Michael Jackson
routines if you've been with me from the
beginning yes
I am actually a bit of a dancer I taught
myself the entire Billie Jean routine
and I don't mean just a cursory glance
of it I literally tried to perfect
everything to the point where I could
make it be as close to his moves as
possible here's a clip enjoy it I told
you guys that give you something special
there you go I like to dance a lot I
might just review step up five this year
just so I can do a dance routine a lot
of people have however asked me for
maybe just just a clip just a clip Chris
Chris please just a clip for one of your
short movies just the little tiny clip
from something so I'll give you
something now this is not meant to be
taken seriously because as I said
earlier I was a teenager and we were
just having fun so here's a little bit
of something from one of our earliest
films enjoy
oh my goodness oh boy guys seriously
thank you so much for watching my stuff
I love doing this I really do
I will not cry uh-uh I can see the
comments out Chris dope and cried in
that video
I can't believe Krystal boo quad crystal
would such a
no but seriously uh you guys I can't
even really express it in words the fact
that so many people enjoy my thoughts on
movies and I it's just I can't even I
can't um type I can't even do it I can't
express the joy that I have to be able
to do this and talk with you guys about
movies I love going to screenings and
watching films and seeing films I still
pay to see films quite often I paid to
see divergent last weekend I don't
always go to screenings I pay to see
quiet in fact pretty much every movie
that came out in January I paid for it
because they didn't have screenings for
half of that garbage seriously though I
don't have another way to say this you
guys are the best people ever and I mean
that I get messages from you on Twitter
Facebook and through email constantly
and I know you guys think I don't read
them but I do
I read my emails I read my Twitter stuff
I read my facebook stuff and I replied
to ones that I think are special and
I've gotten a lot of really great
responses through email somebody told me
the other day that a relative of theirs
had died and that my videos actually got
them out of their house out of their
slump like they watched my videos and
actually felt better about life like how
nuts is that how crazy is that that that
that would happen
you know and I can't even express the
amount of gratitude that I have that
that person would tell me that because I
can't even I just can't
I'm gonna continue doing
reviews for as long as I can I will do
my best to always entertain you guys as
well as always improve my videos that's
one of the biggest things I want to do
is always do my best to improve them
technically you know not just the way I
am but the stuff that I'm using you know
the stuff that can make my videos look
best and sound best I will always try to
do that as well I'll try to see every
movie I can I feel like I am like
pledging myself or something like I will
do everything that I can to be the best
man ever
I know what that was there's a side of
me you guys don't really know about and
it's I guess you do I mean I have a
really idiotic side like oh yeah what am
I talking about you guys know that I say
this movie will make you poop yeah you
guys you guys know that I'm an idiot I
have a very serious side too you know
where I talk about movies and I'm like
I'm gonna make this point and they're
just it's gonna blow their minds because
they're just gonna love it and they have
a sidecar I'm like hey I'm gonna relate
this movie to a pile of poop and I'm
gonna say that a bird ate the poop like
it's like I don't know where these sides
come from but in some way they actually
assist one another and that's one of my
favorite things to do is where I can
actually take some kind of idiotic
juvenile humor and then some real
thought sometimes and put them together
thank you so much for watching guys you
guys are the best I honestly love you
thank you so much for watching my videos
and I look forward to entertaining you
for many many years to come
as always guys if you like this you can
click right here and get stuck man eyes
[Music]